i actually had an entire story that i
broke and
was planning on doing before the
pandemic so
things i'm waiting and things are
shifting also things are shifting
with filmmaking and the studio so i know
gal and i
would love to to make another film
together and we'd love to do another
wonder woman but we'll have to see
this is quite the holiday present to
give fans the release timing is perfect
but i know it's probably been a
difficult journey for you
how difficult of a journey and how much
time did it take for you to reach the
decision to
simultaneously release the film in
theaters and hbo max
for this big blockbuster of a film you
know it's the kind of thing that if you
told me
before this pandemic that we would ever
talk about releasing it
on streaming it would have been the
worst thing that ever had you know it
would have been terrible
the weird thing this year is just so odd
you know and
of course terrible it changes how there
isn't there are no good options really
for so many things in our lives so you
have to look at your priorities and in
my case
definitely as a filmmaker the most
important my number one priority
is is having an you know a shared
experience with
with the world and making something
where you're engaging with your audience
and so
this year that suddenly it felt like a
great way to try to just
listen if you're not going to have the
proper release and you don't know when
that would ever even happen why not give
it away in a holiday season and at least
try to bring some joy to people's lives
this year
were you on board immediately or did it
take you no it took some it took some
thought you know it took some thought
about what all the options were but
you know i got excited too at the mere
idea of it i will say from the first
conversation thank goodness i'm so happy
that you decided to release it and i
know
millions of folks out there are as well
and they are about they got to get ready
for this because it is all sorts of
fabulousness
coming to us from the 80s you know the
parachute pants the shoulder pads the
big hair
you guys nailed it how did you decide on
settling on 1984 specifically
for this film i think of every era
there's like a year that becomes the
quintessential year of that time
so 1984 not only is it the book and the
van halen album and you know all the
great movies that we remember but it
really was i felt like the pinnacle
of the 80s it was quintessential top
of western civilization and so there was
i was really craving having wonder woman
come to our modern world
and and facing enemies born of our
modern times but it was actually the
easiest
thing to do was to demonstrate that in a
different era which was the 80s where
where
that's kind of where we were setting the
stage for everything that we went on to
become but it's so fun to collide her
with that period
how did you decide the new powers the
new classic powers that wonder woman
would embrace
in this film well it was so fun because
really you get to say like what if
you know she's been around doing this
now for a while what would she have
figured out to do well she will have
figured out how to do everything
so much better and so we really set out
to say this is wonder woman at the very
top of her game
she's learned how to utilize every
single thing she has
and god was that fun like coming up with
new things to do with the lasso and the
tiara and all of these different things
it was
so much fun be completely honest with me
here patty because you know we're girls
now
have you and gal talked about have you
floated around the idea
of another wonder woman film and if so
where do you see wonder woman going next
you know i don't know i i actually had
an entire story that i broke
and was planning on doing before the
pandemic now i want to wait and see
see where we are and see what i'm
feeling see what i'm feeling i think
wonder woman would want to talk about
next things i'm waiting and things are
shifting also things are shifting
with filmmaking and the studio so i know
gal and i would love to to make another
film together and we'd love to do
another wonder woman but we'll have to
see
because of like production aspects of
things and yeah
yeah all kinds of all kinds of things
are really changing so we'll have to
you know we we hope it'll come back
again but nothing is set in stone well
i'm going to take that as a
dot indefinite maybe so i'm cheetah oh
my gosh
great villainess to have in the mix for
this film love seeing two powerful women
go at it
like they do what makes kristen wig the
perfect
villainess the perfect cheetah well
kristen is such an amazing
artist and actress i've always thought
she was an incredible actress because
all of the humor that we know her for is
so character based and amazing you know
and i just wanted somebody who could
start playing a character that i knew
she could nail
and then evolve into this much stronger
serious performance and i believed in
her and i believed that she could do it
and like honestly gal and i were super
fans of hers we would follow her around
towards events trying to hang around
with her
the idea that all of those things came
together into this one place was just a
dream
[Music]